I mean the first thing I'd say is this  Sports washing thing is not new 1934 the  second World Cup there was Mussolini was  in power in Italy and he used that  pretty effectively to kind of put his  thing across so so you know already  sport was under the Kosh a little bit  then and then we had Argentina in 1978  which I loved as a kid I mean it was  just glorious and wonderful and uh and  and it's only kind of belatedly that you  read up about all the things that were  going on and you know the Disappeared  people some of them who could actually  hear the games going on from the places  they were incarcerated in and stuff and  you think oh my gosh I had no idea at  the time but this time around we we kind  of do know at the time and I think that  makes a difference ignorance was Bliss  it isn't anymore